you love chocolate and if you love
Thanksgiving then you'll love this okay
Alicia Cerna owner of love chocolate
dessert shop is back to show us how she
does Thanksgiving treats and let me
guess for Thanksgiving you bring dessert
yes okay naturally right so what is
Thanksgiving like for you and your
household what do you guys do um well we
typically go to California and we just
everyone gets together we eat good food
drink a little bit play games we just
spend time together as family I love it
now you have some kids at home and I'm
sure this is really fun for them to
interact with you it's a great activity
with them so let's get into it what are
we making so we're making strawberry
turkeys because you know with
Thanksgiving you can't have Thanksgiving
without Turkey right so super easy all
you need is strawberries mini
marshmallows pretzel sticks and
chocolate I'm using 1101 Deluxe by
silver and Company it's the closest
you're going to get to actual real
chocolate okay
and all you do is just you melt that
yeah you melt you put it in a container
microwave it in intervals on my
Instagram you can go there and check it
out and I'll show you detailed tutorial
on how to do it we were just talking
about the fact that she is the content
Queen you need any dessert tutorials go
to her Instagram page okay let's make it
okay so all you have to do is you'll get
a stick a pretzel stick break it in half
okay and then you're gonna dip your
stick in the chocolate okay
and then grab a little marshmallow and
then just poke it right through okay
oh okay I'm making a mess that's okay
obviously that is and then you're gonna
process wow I'm really bad at this dude
dip that marshmallow inside of the
chocolate right on the side of it
okay and you're gonna stick it on just
like that to your strawberry okay
look look watch this yeah oh it's
sticking it's okay it's sticking oh no
there it goes okay I made one because of
our time and all you have to do is
because I'm awful in the chocolate okay
oh this is the fun part yeah all right
dip it right in there
oh like magic how'd I do perfect perfect
okay you're being nice
go down a little bit more to fully coat
the straws okay but other than that
there you go perfect now lift it up okay
now you have a turkey this is so cool
you don't have to bake it for like seven
to eight hours there you go okay this is
super creative now any other ideas any
other fun tutorials for Thanksgiving
yeah you can check out my Instagram at
love chocolate love chocolate dessert
shop and um all kinds of different
things you could do using orange milk
chocolate holiday sprinkles
it's perfect and for obviously the
holidays Christmas is coming what do you
do for Christmas the big thing for
Christmas for us is hot cocoa bomb so I
know we did something yeah it's
Halloween but Christmas
you could just go crazy with it okay
okay I love that can we can we make one
more yeah can we make one more and now I
want to see you actually do the dipping
and do the sticking because I was so bad
so show them how it's done by the pro
so you do have to wait for the chocolate
to
um kind of dry a little bit that it acts
as a glue wait oh see fail oh
there we go
this is to just hold it
I love it
and the cool thing about this is any age
or any level exactly do it exactly some
might come out a little bit better than
others so you can kind of see you
normally just wait a few seconds or
maybe a minute depending on the humidity
or the temperature all the elements you
have to actually take into consideration
than others and sometimes it'll just
stay very runny okay now while you're
doing that I want to show off the actual
platter did I see this can you see this
Josh the actual platter full of
chocolate turkeys strawberry turkeys I
should say this is perfect to take to
the holiday party or wherever right yeah
and the great thing about these is you
get that freshness from the strawberry
the Crunch and saltiness from the
pretzel it's just it's just amazing one
bite so should I go ahead and take it
right
okay from the bottom yeah there you go
oh wow yeah sweet salty and the
freshness of a nice strawberry and the
chocolate where do you get your
strawberries I actually got those from
Albertsons I believe but also makes the
strawberries Costco has great
strawberries thank you so much again
what's your Instagram I love chocolate
dessert shop yes